what's up guys a couple years ago we  built a really cool gun wall for all our  prop guns but since then not only has  jake got a degree in law and a doctorate  in engineering but we got way more guns  so we got to keep them all somewhere so  he built a brand new gun wall that's  even cooler than our last one let's go  not bad not bad but well this is the new  thing this is what i'm really excited  about they installed lights in here too  check this out  ooh  shiny yeah  man which one's my favorite i like this  one a lot this one's cool jake what  about you i'm always a big fan of shot  shot shotguns man just class nice i'm  going with the uh glock over here  not a glock my favorite gun is probably  this gun  what's your favorite gun revolver  classic boom that's great  some of them are loaded you're just  leaving